my friend Kurt Cameron has a new
children's book out celebrating Faith
and family it's called as you grow I
don't have a copy yet so I haven't read
it but I'm sure it's great you know Kirk
Cameron very famous actor probably even
more famous for being the nicest and
most wholesome and least objectionable
guy you will ever meet in your entire
life well
apparently some people are objecting to
Kirk apparently more than 50 public
libraries are objecting to Kirk and have
rejected him from presenting his book at
reading hours for communities around the
country
doesn't make a lot of sense to me
especially when you learn that many of
those same libraries host drag queen
story hours and similarly degenerate
performances for little kids one such
Library Rochambeau Public Library
promotes something they call Queer
umbrella which the library says is quote
open to all members of the lgbtq plus
Community who are 12 years and older
12 years old
if you're a 12 year old kid who's maybe
a little bit confused about sex and what
12 year old isn't by the way especially
these days then the library wants you to
come on down
and hear some creepy dude in stilettos
lecture you about all sorts of weird sex
stuff tell you if you're a boy that
maybe you're you're a girl that sort of
thing but if you are a kid of any age
who wants to learn about family and
faith and good normal stuff
you're out of luck because Kirk Cameron
doesn't have stilettos at least to my
knowledge Kirk doesn't have any mini
skirts to wear Kirk Cameron just has a
nice family and a stable life and a nice
book about how to live life in
accordance with the good the true and
the Beautiful and that message is
considered far too dangerous by the
surprisingly powerful people who want
your kids all to themselves I'm Michael
Knowles is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Greg boundary
who says all I want for Christmas is for
Michael's producers to bring back the
Bell whenever he says the title of his
book speechless controlling words
controlling Minds this is partially for
the small dopamine hit every time the
Bell goes off but also to remember back
to a simpler time where we thought
naively that the end of our Republic was
on the horizon and not at our front door
let alone a year and a half behind us a
great point a great point and I agree I
I too want that for Christmas I really
want that for Advent so that it can ding
if I mention the title of my book in the
lead up to Christmas because as you know
one of the finest Christmas gifts you
can possibly give to your friends and
relatives would be the number one
National best-selling book speechless
controlling words controlling Minds hey
all right baby now we're talking
that's great wow that's great stuff you
can add that to your cart right now
speechless
hello
hello thank you speechless
just get it again all right they got to
work out the Kinks in the producer room
in the meantime you know what you can do
you can protect your home with rain
right now head on over to ring.com
collections slash offers with the
holidays coming up many of us will be
traveling to see our families and loved
ones very very soon you may find
yourself away from home more often than
not that is why I've teamed up with a
ring with ring security products you can
rest easy knowing that your home and
family are safe when you're not there
the ring doorbell notifies you when
guests or packages arrive a Rings indoor
cameras let you keep an eye on kids and
pets while you're away ring alarm will
alert you of any motion detection while
the house is empty plus if you had smart
lighting around your home you can turn
lights on or off while you are away
Rings home security products don't only
keep your home and family safe they also
make perfect gifts for everybody on your
list I love ring it makes me feel a lot
better when I'm away from home it's not
only something that I have gotten but I
have given it out to my friends makes a
great housewarming gift makes a great
Christmas present head on over to
ring.com collection slash offers to find
out how you can live less stressed this
season with a ring product that is right
for you that is ring.com collections
slash offers you just don't believe what
is going on even if you read it in the
papers you just don't believe what is
going on in the libraries even if you
see it on the news you just don't
believe what is going on in the schools
drag queens and stilettos get to dance
around for toddlers Kirk Cameron doesn't
get to read a nice book about family but
that is going on and it's so much worse
than that James O'Keefe at project
Veritas has just come out with an expose
man named Joseph Bruno Joseph Bruno dean
of students at Francis W Parker school
this is in Chicago the Francis W Parker
school is a private school that goes all
the way up to 12th grade goes all the
way down to pre-k and here is what Dean
Bruno had to say about his lesson plans
I had like our lgbtq plus Health Center
come in they were passing around butt
plugs and dildos to my students talking
about queer sex using Lou versus using
spit meet Joe Bruno dean of students at
the prestigious branches W Parker
private school in Chicago which happens
to charge forty thousand dollars per
student they're just like passing on
dildos butt plugs the kids are just
playing with them they're like how do
you how does this book work how do I do
like how does this work that's a really
like a little part of my job parents
might be stunned to learn that Bruno's
version of love and acceptance means
handing out sex toys to underage
students
that's a really cool part of his job you
know that's the really cool part
what's so devastating about this clip is
one it's more obscene even than I would
expect and my head is in the news all
day long it is very hard to shock me
with anything going on in our schools
and and wherever these radicals rain
but this is a private school
this is a school that parents pay forty
thousand dollars for this is this is
what happens when you look at the public
schools and you say man the public
schools are so bad they're so crazy
they're filling our kids heads with such
nonsense especially in Chicago okay I'm
gonna take this big Financial hit I'm
going to pay a full College tuition
every single year pre-k through grade 12
to send my kid to this private school so
that he can be
groomed into weird creepy sex stuff from
a very very young age while the dean of
students is Giddy and bragging about it
that's how bad
it is and we don't believe it because
we we're always about five years behind
we conservatives
we do we're always kind of fighting the
last battle and the libs have moved on
and it just kind of breaks our brains
even listening to that my brain just
kind of breaks I think it can't what
does he really mean what is he really
saying he can't possibly mean that that
is what he means that is what he is
doing now the good news is conservatives
are winning a little bit
at pushing back on some of the woke
stuff we're not really winning in the
schools all that well we're not really
winning in the media all that well we're
not really winning at The Ballot Box
these days all that well we are winning
on one front though and that would be
the ESG agenda we are winning on the
investor side of things you've heard
about ESG that's the environmental
social and governance policies that are
is just a kind of woke Smorgasbord of
policies that major asset managers uh
demand that the companies that they
invest in start to put into effect the
example that I keep using
is that Cracker Barrel the other day I
was driving past a sign for Cracker
Barrel and it said come try our new
vegetarian sausage it's the impossible
sausage it doesn't have any meat in it
and I thought
wow ESG is real because the vegetarian
sausage at Cracker Barrel is obviously
not in response to any consumer demand
it's not in response to Market forces
not one single vegetarian has ever
walked into Cracker Barrel not once okay
this is obviously in response to some
woke Looney Tune calling them up from
the asset managers and saying hey you
need to wokeify your menu
so what did I do I Googled I said who
are the investors in Cracker Barrel and
what do you know I forget who was number
one and who was number two and who was
number three but it was BlackRock
Vanguard State streets all these guys
that are the the big asset managers who
are pushing this so really good news
Vanguard is pulling out of the zero Net
Zero asset managers initiative
Net Zero asset managers initiative is
one of these far left environmentalist
policies being pushed in our economy
Vanguard which is one of the three
biggest asset managers is is pulling out
of that why is Vanguard pulling out
Vanguard says it's going to withdraw to
quote provide the clarity our investors
desire about the role of index funds and
about how we think about material risks
including climate related risks okay
kind of a bland statement well you know
we just want to provide some more
clarity on how we're using our investors
money yeah okay who are the investors
though is Vanguard doing that because
you or I maybe have some money in
Vanguard or our retirement accounts or
somehow tied to Vanguard or not really
the reason why Vanguard is doing this is
because states are pulling their money
from these woke funds
it wouldn't be enough if it were just me
and you it wouldn't be enough if it were
the entire daily wire daily wire has a
million members and we have many
millions of readers and listeners across
all of our shows and website we've got a
million active members who are paying a
bunch of money to support the daily wire
program very much on board if every
single one of us called up Vanguard
tomorrow and said pull your money from
these woke initiatives Vanguard would
laugh at us okay that's not enough but
what did happen it wasn't just
some group of people some Community even
a big company like the daily wire the
state of Texas called okay the state of
Texas announced
that they are pulling out of the these
these woke asset managers people like
Vanguard State Street BlackRock you've
seen similar moves from Red States all
around the country
and we've been reporting on this for
about six months now this is key and I
hope that conservatives learn the lesson
the lesson here is
that what fixed this problem or what is
starting to fix this problem is not the
market
it's not the free exchange of ideas and
goods and services what fit is fixing
this problem right now is wielding
political power what is fixing this
problem right now is the heavy hand of
the state okay people electing
Republicans putting them into office as
state treasurers and similar offices and
then those State treasurers punishing
these companies and saying you jerks if
you keep using investor money to both
retail investors and big institutional
investors big state investors like us we
are going to punish you and we're going
to pull our money out we don't give a
damn what your returns are we're gonna
pull it out because we don't want you
pushing your weird creepy leftist
policies and what happens
the asset managers blank
that's a very very good thing
conservatives used to understand how to
build political power they haven't in
the last couple of decades 10 20 years
ago you would have heard the
conservatives say well it's that's not
right that's fascism if the if the state
treasurers call the asset managers and
say don't trans the kids and get rid of
all of the food that we like and upend
our way of life that's that's fascism
it's authoritarian you can we we can't
ever stop the left from controlling our
corporations yet no we can't oh that's
called self-government okay that's
that's why we elect these people in the
first place
is to put the will of the people within
the bounds of law and the Constitution
into effect
we're not going to make an idol out of
environmentalism we're not going to make
an idol out of the weird sex stuff we're
not even going to make an idol out of
the free market this ideal that doesn't
actually exist in practice we are going
to say hey politicians put your
constituents first and and represent our
views because we are supposed to live in
a self-governing republic
and by golly we're going to keep trying
to live in one as long as we possibly
can one way to prolong our Republic is
to spread the messages of prageru our
country might be heading in the wrong
direction but prageru videos could help
save the future of America prageru makes
educational pro-american content that
has been changing people's minds for
over a decade their impact is pivotal in
these times did you know that 70 percent
of viewers have changed their minds
after watching a prageru video did you
know that 60 of viewers are under the
age of 35. my friends over at prageru
are reaching millions of people with
their educational videos but they have a
long way to go you can help prageru
reach thousands more people by joining
Club five for just five dollars or more
per month five dollars per month is only
17 cents per day 17 cents per day is
less than one cent per hour okay it's
nothing to get all that great Prager you
content the five minute videos the kids
content The Book Club hosted by your
doors truly your gift will ensure that
prageru has the support it needs to be
here for the Long Haul join a movement
with thousands of fellow Patriots in the
fight to save America help Prairie you
reach thousands more people with
messages of Truth Liberty American
values join Club 5 today and receive a
free Prager you bumper sticker plus an
e-book of scripts from pragary's five
minute videos join at prageru.com Club
five today
until recently
it seemed as though the state
was only being wielded by the left
and the right was pretty much
surrendering on that okay but the left
was wielding the state
to great effect we're learning more
about that now so you know about the
Twitter file story we've been talking
about it which is where the the DNC
colluded with Twitter
to censor conservatives to give an
advantage to Joe Biden possibly to swing
the election to Joe Biden specifically
through the censorship of the hunter
Biden laptop story but until now until
uh the machinations of Twitter and the
Deep state became clear Elon Musk
revealed them just a couple of days ago
that actually the lawyer at Twitter who
was vetting the Twitter files
release and expose actually had been a
major and controversial FBI lawyer the
whole thing just stunk to high heaven
but we do know that the FBI was putting
pressure on Twitter with regard to the
hunter Biden laptop story we have a
report from the New York Post that shows
that the FBI sent frequent and fake
warnings to Twitter in October 2020
about the upcoming hack and leak
operation of the targeted Hunter Biden
one of the arguments for censoring the
hunter Biden laptop story was that it
was hacked material but it wasn't hacked
material Hunter Biden presumably on some
Bender just dropped his broken laptop
off at a repairman and didn't pick it up
and then the repairman gave it to Rudy
Giuliani it gets even more corrupt
though how did the FBI even know about
the laptop the FBI knew about the laptop
because they were spying on Rudy
Giuliani why were they spying on Rudy
Giuliani well they just made up a reason
that they ended up dropping so this is
according to Miranda Devine who was the
person who broke the hunter Biden laptop
story at the New York Post she said
the FBI was spying on Trump's then
lawyer Rudy giuliani's online Cloud
under the pretext of an investigation
into alleged foreign agent registration
violations a probe which conveniently
was dropped this year do you remember
that I vaguely remember this from the
2020 campaign there was this allegation
that Rudy Giuliani had done all this
work for foreign powers and so the the
FBI apparently was investigating him but
it was all bogus it was just totally
fake it was the same sort of fake
pretext that you saw the last time the
FBI spied on Trump when they spied on
Carter page when they spied on the Trump
campaign in 2015 and 2016.
so it was just it was just bogus and
then the FBI found out about this and
they said yikes uh oh we can't have this
dirt on Biden getting out and then they
send these bogus warnings to Twitter and
Facebook and lied and said that it was
hacked material and then Twitter and
Facebook and Google of course censored
the information it's just so
it's so corrupt but you gotta hand it to
the libs
it was an effective operation
okay immoral unjust wrong I don't think
Republicans should engage in this kind
of thing
but we should wield the state we should
have our own effective
political State operations
now ours I would like to not break the
law and to not be immoral but come on
guys we can't just surrender the whole
field all right the libs wield the state
very very well Republicans on just a
handful of times we actually try it as
in the case of the ESG asset managers as
in the case of defunding
woke Incorporated which is what these
State treasurers are doing right now it
works really really well keep it up
let's do more of that let's stop being
so government phobic let's stop being so
political power phobic if Republicans
aren't going to wield political power
there's no reason to give it to them
ever there's no reason for people ever
to vote for them
now the libs aren't going to give up
wielding political power they're trying
now they're actually still going after
Twitter the mayor of San Francisco
London breed
has launched a new investigation into
Twitter what could they possibly be
investigating Twitter for now what could
they possibly be doing
Elon Musk has just made this acquisition
the whole thing was so public it was all
in court what on Earth the guy has fired
a lot of his staff or the staff is
voluntarily left so there aren't even
that many people you could pot what on
Earth could they possibly investigate
him for
beds
and I know how that sounds they're not
investigating Twitter for any alleged
sex stuff going on
they're investigating Twitter because
Elon Musk has brought some beds in to
allow employees who are working around
the clock to take little naps when Elon
Musk took over he said look to get
Twitter back on the right track it's on
the brink of collapse to get it back on
the right track we're going to need a
core team of very competent people to
work a lot Elon Musk obviously works
constantly he's famously a workaholic he
said but we need people
to start showing up before Elon Musk
took over most of Twitter wasn't even
showing up to the office
it was just that coveted vacation going
on into 2022. and Elon said you got to
show up can't be working these six seven
hour days folks you're gonna need to be
working a lot to right the ship
and so as a courtesy he provides some
beds if you ever want to take a nap
San Francisco says no it's a zoning
issue violation they're sending in
building inspectors
to launch an investigation to make sure
the building is being used as intended
so what would they rather have happen
would they rather have the Twitter
employees taking naps in bathroom stalls
as happens on Wall Street it's what
happens for the the young Associates at
Wall Street Banks who are working
15-hour days or more 16 18 hour days
sometimes they'll just go in and take a
stall nap for 10 is that what they want
or would it be nicer to be able to go
lie down on a couch lie down on a bed or
something like that take a 20 minute nap
get right back to work
no of course though it has nothing to do
with zoning worries no one really thinks
that Twitter's turned into an apartment
building it's just about constantly
harassing the workers can you imagine
what what the left-wing companies are
doing we know actually with Google
Google has all sorts of these amenities
no one ever launches an investigation
into Google why because Google does the
bidding of the liberal establishment the
moment that Elon Musk who is kind of on
the left he's not he's not some rock
ribbed conservative the moment that he
steps out of line they use the full
force of the state to try to shut him
down
so they're really busy investigating the
linen at Twitter headquarters in San
Francisco so they don't really have time
to subpoena
the greatest Financial scam artist
potentially of all time
Sam bankman freed who is responsible for
the collapse of FTX the second largest
cryptocurrency exchange he lost zillions
and zillions of dollars of investor
money in a scam a scam where he was
where he was illicitly using money from
his alleged investors and the people who
were who were trading on his
cryptocurrency platform to just back
funnel it into a hedge fund that he was
running he with his
kind of eccentric girlfriend and this
gaggle of Misfit kids who were running a
kind of weird
amphetamine fueled sex cult in the
Bahamas
you can't no we're not going to
investigate that guy but Elon is he
brought a couple mattresses into Twitter
so we've got to sick the feds on him how
do we know that the Democrats are not
going to subpoena
Sam bankman freed SBF well because
Maxine Waters anti-maxine house
Financial Services committee chairman
she she said she's not going to do it
she tweets out she says you know
Sam bankman freed your willingness
to talk to the public will help the
company's customers investors and others
to that end we would welcome your
participation in our hearing on the 13th
this is
as gentle an invitation as you can
possibly get hey would you would you
mind maybe if you're if you're free if
you can leave the amphetamine-fueled
orgies for a moment and get off your
pile of money that you stole from people
could you would you mind showing up to
Capitol Hill please to talk about your
theft and he responds
absolutely not a fear in the world he
says once I finished learning and
reviewing what happened I would feel
like it was my duty to appear before the
committee and explain
I'm not sure that will happen by the
13th but when it does I will testify
okay
that's fine no big deal
it's one of the greatest crimes not of
the century this is one of the greatest
Crimes of the past several centuries
we're talking about the theft of so much
money instantly billions and 15 and a
half billion dollars disappear overnight
and just in just in sambang refried's
supposed net worth
not so okay well you let me know when
you're ready Sam why
Maxine Waters will not subpoena
sandbankment freed over the FTX collapse
because
she has no incentive to
because Sam bankman freed bankrolled not
just her
bankrolled all of the Democrats he was
the second largest donor to Democrats in
this last election cycle
so now the Democrats aren't going to
subpoena him and he's not afraid that
he's really going to be subpoenaed this
is a symbiotic relationship
where
you scratch my back I scratch your back
no big deal on it an insane skill think
about what the new story we just got
yesterday that the Attorney General in
New York and all these investigators
have spent how many years now
investigating Donald Trump's business
building a case against him throwing
everything they can at him wasting it
who knows how many millions of dollars
of taxpayer money to find out that two
divisions of the Trump organization sort
of fudged their taxes a little bit and
levied a 1.6 million dollar fine on them
yeah we got you now Trump we're gonna
get 1.6 million dollars from you New
York Times calls it a rounding error
meanwhile you've got the biggest
Financial scam ever going on but it's a
Democrat donor
who is who is the head of that scam and
so okay never mind sweep it under the
rug
it is so so crooked and speaking of
corruption in our government we've got
this new report here right here from the
daily wire
about how the CIA may have had a
relationship with the man who killed
Kennedy
we're still debating the man who killed
Kennedy all these years later and what's
what's so interesting about it
is how the sides have sort of flipped
in people's theories
Lee Harvey Oswald he's the man who
killed Kennedy new report says
that Oswald was tied to the CIA
for the JFK assassination right before
the JFK assassination why is this coming
out now Jefferson Morley
is a journalist and an author and he
said this during a press conference in
D.C on Tuesday this is less than two
weeks before the December 15th deadline
to release still classified records
related to the JFK assassination so even
now 60 70 years later uh no I guess
about six years later we've got
uh
information that is still classified
about the Kennedy assassination
and Morley who's this journalist says
quote what the CIA is hiding is what
they've always hidden which is their
sources and methods as they relate to
Lee Harvey Oswald we're talking about
Smoking Gun proof of a CIA operation
involving Lee Harvey Oswald asserting
that this took place in the summer of
1963 not long before the Kennedy
assassination and Oswald later denied
Killing Kennedy he said that he was just
a patsy
and then of course we never had a trial
because Lee Harvey Oswald was shot dead
on national TV at the Dallas Police
Headquarters by Jack Ruby
now the story has always been that Lee
Harvey Oswald acted alone only one
gunman government didn't know anything
government didn't do anything and speed
conspiracy theories have always swirled
around I don't use that term derisively
as we know these days the difference
between a conspiracy theory and the
truth is about three to six months but I
just mentioned it because they are
theories about potential conspiracies
involving the Communists involving the
mob involving the government involving
all sorts of people
involving LBJ and but they're all sorts
of theories about this
the most interesting part of the story
to me
is that
but the whole time I was growing up
the people who peddled
the conspiracy theories about the
Kennedy assassination that is the people
who did not believe the official
government story
we're on the left it was always the
leftist it was always Oliver Stone it
was always these these far left Wingers
who said no it was the CIA you know what
was this it was that
the people on the right
generally accepted the government story
and said no look the guy was a communist
and a communist went out and killed
Kennedy and that's that a simple simple
case
that has started to change
today the roles have basically flipped
today it is even beyond the Kennedy
assassination it is the left
that defends the CIA it is the left that
defends the FBI it is the left that
defends the Deep State and the
government it is the right that is very
skeptical of all of those organizations
it is the right it is skeptical of all
of those institutions
what does this represent well it just
represents in the perception the popular
perception
20 30 years ago
there was this perception that
the Republicans were kind of the
establishment
I'm not saying that was true I'm just
saying that was the perception today it
is firmly established in the minds of
everybody the libs control all those
institutions the libs control the
government and the Deep State and all
the rest of it and the libs lie through
those institutions constantly
and the conservatives aren't realizing
this so conservatives saw this right up
close during covid
the conservatives saw this right up
close during the FBI scam the Russia
hoax the conservatives saw this right up
close during the New FBI scam put
pressuring big Tech to censor the 100
Biden laptop story The conservatives saw
this up close with the FBI Scandal when
Obama's IRS went after conservative
groups
we've just seen this so much for years
and so when when people raise questions
about the Kennedy assassination
especially on the right
that's not the conservative's fault
that's not the fault of of tin foil hat
fueled crazy conspiracy theories
it's the fault of the deep State it's
the fault of those institutions its
fault of the left which has wielded them
in a very corrupt way speaking of John
Kennedy a different John Kennedy Senator
John Kennedy has a Manifesto for
conservatives a clip that just went
viral a few days ago
they hate George Washington
they hate Thomas Jefferson
they hate Dr Zeus and they hate Mr
Potato Head
the these woke
high IQ stupid people they walk around
they walk around with Ziploc bags of
kale
that they can eat to give them energy
now if you want to eat kale that's up to
you
I don't eat kale you know why because
kale tastes to me like I'd rather be fat
and these high iqp stupid people the
walkers in charge of Washington DC the
berserk wind of the Democratic Party
they hyperventilate on their yoga mats
if if you use the wrong pronoun they're
all over Washington DC
here here
I I Adore this bit I had I absolutely
adore this stump speech from John
Kennedy
uh it's not the most specific one well
it is specific in the details of the
jokes he's making
but I just love this idea
of going after the high IQ stupid people
in this really clunky comedic way
because
John Kennedy is an extremely intelligent
and extremely educated man
this guy has has degrees from Vanderbilt
UVA and modeling College Oxford in the
United Kingdom this guy is very very
educated
and it comes out and he talks like
Foghorn Leghorn and really the the
comparison that I see here
is with
Norm Macdonald Norm Macdonald also
brilliant brilliant guy not particularly
educated self-educated but it's really
an extraordinarily intelligent guy
who would play kind of a dummy they'd
say oh yeah man I'm not really a smart
guy you know or anything like that Matt
died
and then he would just hit you with
something that was so
sharp and incisive and would destroy the
pretensions of our supposedly genius
Bettors who run the world
the the thing that conservatives have to
do well one what it embodies is a kind
of humility where we don't need to
always seem like the fanciest people in
the world and we're all we believe in
all the really fashionable theories and
we oh yes we're taken very seriously
though the cocktail parties and all
these nice fancy apartments in New York
and now and we gotta forget about that
there's a kind of humility that says no
I'd rather be with truck drivers than
with the Dr fauces of the world the
truck drivers actually understand the
world better okay and I know that's not
how it's presented in the popular
culture but it is the case fauci wrong
about everything truckers write about a
lot of things maybe not everything but a
lot of things okay that's just the way
that it works Roger scrutin said that
the job of a conservative intellectual
is to articulate
things that Ordinary People understand
intuitively
yeah it's kind of a nice job
because normal people kind of get it and
it's just the self-styled intellectual
Elite of our ruling class that don't
understand these sorts of things what
conservatives have to do
is
awaken people from the intellectual
trance of our idiotic Elite because
there are a lot of people especially
young people especially people in
uh college and high school and where all
of the the elite leftists are really
preying on them and trying to warp their
minds who who they want to be the smart
people they say well all the people in
the fancy lab coats all the people with
the fancy neckties they're all on the
left and we need to awaken people to
that and point out that these are high
IQ stupid people
I'm sure that a lot of our Elite have
relatively High IQs but they're stupid
they say things that are not true they
say things like men can become women
they say things like babies are in
people they say things like the world's
going to end in five years because of
the sun monster they say all sorts of
stupid things and I I think the John
Kennedy approach is a great way to do it
I'm saying y'all hear about this I don't
want to eat kale because kale when I
taste it it makes me want to be fat
it's it's a great bit now speaking of
many of the things we've just been
discussing lizzo
just
attempted to normalize abortion
at the People's Choice Awards
mono co-founder of shout your abortion
who was working to normalize abortion
increase awareness of abortion pills
people to work and supportive abortion
access in their communities make some
noise
yeah we still going yeah we're still
going kill all your babies
yeah we're gonna go and we're and then
she goes down the line with all the
other what causes and the abortion lady
she talked to holds up a sign and it
says abortion pills forever yeah pop
that poison pill and Murder Your
Precious Child wow and then the crowd is
just out there they're like wow give us
Barabbas wow yeah give us Paramus and
you look at the scene
and you think you know
it was ever thus
it was ever thus we are tempted to look
at these things and say wow oh man this
has never happened before maybe the
specific iterations of The Madness of
crowds has never happened before but
this sort of reaction
to wicked false evil things this has
happened this often happens okay
if you were to watch that clip with the
sound off those of you who are listening
in the car right now if you
go back and watch it you turn the sound
off
you could still tell not hearing a word
that they're saying that these people
are on the wrong side of things
you could tell because
no one there seems to be in control of
their passions
they just seem like a ravenous
repetitive
monstrous sort of crowd
there's lizzo just screaming and kind of
gesticulating wildly everywhere she's
obviously not in control of a lot of her
life and then the Mad crowd like yes
give us the babies yeah give me so I
could kill the babies and then you've
got the woman she points to and she's
well I shaking that sign yeah let's keep
you and and they're obviously not not in
control of themselves so it's actually a
kind of encouragement
when you look back and see how the truth
has been treated throughout history it
is an encouragement to those of us who
are living today and we say wow no one's
ever had it this bad well you know look
what they did to Socrates okay who said
a lot of true things look what they did
to Jesus who is the truth
okay this is this is what crowds do
this is often what political Roots do
because the prince of this world is the
devil who is the father of Lies okay so
that that sort of thing is going to
happen we are going to have a tough slog
it doesn't matter though we should we
should take comfort we're in this Advent
season right now we should take comfort
because
our Lord has overcome the world okay we
know how the story ends the story ends
happily but there will be a lot of
tribulation in the meantime there will
be a lot of challenge in the meantime
it's okay that's a that's a a good thing
all right it's it's an honor to be born
into a time of great Challenge and a
Great Tribulation the way that we are
going to
have success the way we are going to
overcome these things is
ballot to be sort of childlike it gets
back to what John Kennedy's comedy
routine there it gets back to the the
wisdom of Norm Macdonald it gets back to
how we stand up to the people who run
the academic institutions and all the
media we just ask kind of simple
questions we say I know I just saw you I
saw your whole scientific presentation I
I listened to your whole lecture about
how 12 year olds need to be
indoctrinated into weird sex toy stuff
and how boys are actually girls and how
we need to kill all of the babies and
how the Sun monster is going to eat us
all in five years but I know I I just
bet
is that is that real doesn't make a
whole lot of sense to me I you know I
think I'm gonna stick with the good
old-fashioned way of doing things all
over the country
wives mothers sisters and daughters are
standing up for the strong men and boys
in their lives by kicking woke razor
companies out of their bathroom and
replacing them with Jeremy's razors
Jeremy's razors is a premium Men's
Grooming company that shockingly does
not hate men the Precision 5 razor will
trim his beard not his masculinity and
the new American-made hair body and
skincare line has got his whole routine
covered it's a win-win you love that
he's cleaning up without parabens or
sulfates he loves that he's supporting a
company that doesn't hate his guts
Jeremy's razors is 100 woke free
now 30 off when you order by December
15th other so-called men's care brands
they work to make guys feel bad Jeremy
just wants to make you look great okay
kick those woke companies out of your
man's bathroom this Christmas go to
dailywire.com
today get 30 off this gift bundle
of attention addicts
there's a writer and producer
for Gray's Anatomy who's who's in the
midst of a big Scandal right now
this woman has just been exposed as
having made a whole bunch of claims
about her life that turned out not to be
true
so this woman
has claimed This Woman's name is a finch
Finch
forget I forget what her first name is
no it doesn't really matter she's a
writer producer I'm Gray's Anatomy very
popular show and
she had a real sob story she said that
she had cancer
very bad
and an abortion
that's that's very bad too and a kidney
loss oh that's very bad and then her
brother killed himself wow that's very
bad and then
she had to take a leave of absence do
you think man I mean I know when it
rains it pours but this lady she's like
Dr Doom over here everything just keeps
going wrong for her she takes a leave of
absence ultimately she resigns from the
show turns out it was all fake she just
made all of it up
she said quote when you get wrapped up
in a lie you forget who you told what
you said to this person and whether this
person knows that thing and that's the
world where you can get caught
she just kind of came clean in this long
interview with the ankler so I don't
need to worry about that now how did it
all start it started because she got a
knee injury it was a that was the real
part it wasn't that she got cancer and
an abortion and lost a kidney and her
brother killed himself the real issue is
she hurt her knee a little bit and then
she said instead of getting addicted to
medication
she became addicted to all the attention
that she was getting all the Care all
the pity and sympathy that she was
getting and so as she recovered she
started to lose that attention in that
sympathy and she was so desperate to get
it back that she made up all of these
problems
this all started to unravel when she met
this woman Jennifer Byer it turns out
this lady Finch is a lesbian and so she
meets this lady and then they have a
romantic relationship together and the
lady says hey hey man hey hey lady you
gotta you're lying you gotta come clean
about all of this and she does complain
so obviously look this this is a very
troubled woman she's got all sorts of
confusion in all parts of her life
but it's not just her
this is the whole culture
the whole culture
exalts victimhood we know that I'm not
saying anything you haven't heard before
victimhood carries currency in our
culture that is why we're told that
white people have privilege and black
people are oppressed and why why we have
so many instances of white women
pretending to be black
it doesn't
let's just go with the premise for a
second that there is such a thing as
white privilege and there is such a
thing as black oppression in America
just just go with them for a moment
well if that's all true then why is it
that the people who supposedly believe
that
often are white people who then pretend
to be black Rachel dollazole that NYU
Professor a number of other people in
these high-profile cases
why is it that uh Jesse Smollett
pretends to be robbed by white
supremacists in Maga country with a
noose and a Subway sandwich
why is it that virtually every time you
see I hate hoax on campus racial or
sexual
it it turns out to be just that it turns
out to be fake whenever you see the
n-word written on a dorm room wall guess
who wrote it 999 times out of a thousand
it's going to be the black student
himself every time you see a noose
hanging on campus who put it there every
time you see a swastika who put it it's
always done by the alleged victims
why
because victim who does currency but why
does victimhood have currency that's the
question a lot of people won't answer
the reason that victimhood is carrying
currency right now is because
our culture
cannot attain excellence
I'm sure we could we're just not willing
to do the things that are required to
attain excellence and so
because we're in in a normal society the
way you get social currency is by doing
impressive things by doing by being
physically excellent intellectually
excellent achieving something in
business or politics
but today if you're physically really
strong and beautiful and fit that's
called tax toxic masculinity we got to
get rid of that's awful that's evil if
you're really really beautiful oh you're
just conforming to those evil
traditional social norms and Beauty
Norms if you build a big successful
business you're a greedy evil capitalist
you probably only got that by exploiting
people and this is just because
uh people are not inclined they're not
willing to put in the work they're not
really willing to accept the humility
that is required to attain excellence
and so a culture that refuses to attain
excellence
is going to be a culture that elevates
Frailty infirmity
victimhood that's what's happening
and so you're going to see a lot more of
it this confused lady on Gray's Anatomy
she's just
she is the tip of the iceberg okay she
is one Exemplar of a very sick culture
even the most celebrated and privileged
people do this Jennifer Lawrence just
did an interview with variety Jennifer
Lawrence one of the most celebrated
wealthy privileged people in the world
Jennifer Lawrence talking about how she
overcame or oppression however how
oppressed she still is
but I remember when I was doing Hunger
Games nobody had ever put a woman in the
lead of an action movie because it
wouldn't work we were told girls and
boys can both identify with a male lead
but boys cannot identify with a female
lead oh absolutely and it just makes me
so happy every single time I see a movie
come out that just blows through every
single one of those beliefs and proves
that it is just a lie to keep certain
people out of the movies to keep certain
people in the same positions that
they've always been in and it's just
amazing to watch it happen and watch you
at the helm
Lara Croft is the hardest hit there were
before Jennifer Lawrence there were no
female stars of action movies
I thought I don't watch a lot of movies
a lot of new movies so I thought oh
maybe is that true and wait a second
what about Lara Croft remember that from
2000 2001 it was like 20 years ago we
had a female Action Hero and then I kind
of Googled it looked it up
there was Linda Hamilton
obviously in Terminator 1984 Sigourney
Weaver and aliens 1986.
Bridget Fonda 1993 point of no return
Gina Davis and the longest good night
1996.
you've got uh well obviously you've got
Uma Thurman Kill Bill
you've got uh uh Milla Jovovich I don't
know how to pronounce her name but
Resident Evil you remember Resident Evil
that was also 2003. so
you know there have been a bunch of
women who were action stars and it
wasn't
wasn't really all that hard for Jennifer
Lawrence at all compared to any other
actress
compared to any other actor for that
matter
but it's not enough for Jennifer
Lawrence to go out and say I'm really
beautiful
I'm really
privileged I'm real I'm in all of these
movies I'm very wealthy I'm no that
she has to frame it as I overcame
such oppression that still exists and so
what's the point she's making by the way
even to the point that she's making she
says you know it was just commonly
understood that uh everyone can identify
with a male action hero but not everyone
can identify with a female Action Hero
well yeah that's true that part is true
that part's obviously true
why there are more male action heroes
than female action heroes of course
because there are more men engaged in
public action in the world
than there are women
and especially when we're talking about
action movies because that typically
requires physical strength and men are
stronger than women
what she's really complaining about here
is that
the movies even big Sensational movies
even action movies are reflecting
reality too much
and that's that's terrible it's it's
this insistence that no no the women
have to be like the men
the the this is it's wrong to portray
men doing things that men ordinarily and
traditionally and naturally would do
know that women have to do that too wow
wow I hate reality that's what it that's
what it so often comes down to wow wow I
hate reality
uh Kirk Cameron has a book coming out on
how family is good and faith is good and
we're the good true and beautiful things
that you should follow no we can't have
that
that's too in line with reality no no
we've just got to pass out a gay sex
toys to kids pre-k through grade 12 in
Chicago no that's what we have to we
have to constantly contradict reality
because of how offensive it is and then
when reality reasserts itself when it
rears its ugly head we can whine and
complain
even when we're the most privileged
famous wealthy people on the face of the
Earth if that doesn't if that does not
convince you
to avoid leftism if that does not
convince you to live a more conservative
life I don't know what will because you
look at conservatives
even conservatives with very humble
Stations don't have a lot of money that
don't have a lot of power don't have a
lot of influence
they're very often quite content
and you look at the most famous powerful
richest influential leftists in the
world
and they're almost always miserable
they get into really weird stuff the
further up you go the more you get into
the realm of high luxury and and you
know hot Couture and all these sorts of
things well Balenciaga you look at
Balenciaga the faces of Balenciaga the
most famous wealthy people on Earth and
what's what's Balenciaga peddling
blood guts and Gore and chains and
Dungeons and pedophilia and Satanism and
all this really weird stuff that I don't
understand
perhaps in part because I'm a man so I
have a panel of women here to explain it
to me the rest of the show continues now
you do not want to miss it if you're not
a member click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
[Music]